[Música]
[Aplausos]
olá eo vale reflete com voz sobre o
futuro da democracia
como é que vai ser dentro de 30 dias
mas primeiro que ia fazer convosco um
que lhes é difícil imaginar uma festa
conhecem alguém sempre vir no futuro
porém como eu
nossa reação é mais ou menos esta dizer
e tentar sair da conversão mais pressa
mas imaginei que o vosso interlocutor
insista íris não consegue ver tudo no
futuro mas consigo prever quem vai
ganhar as eleições e livrar os governos
em três países estados unidos reino
unido e online
porém como eu está a disputar a voz e
curiosidade então pela a este inesperado
vivendo no futuro político
aí eu estou no reino unido vão ganhar os
trabalhistas
[Música]
os estados unidos vão ganhar os
republicanos ganharam mercado ou esse aí
imagina o que vossa ea pensar e
principalmente dizer ao vosso inesperado
vidente
estas previsões não tem nada de especial
na verdade é que olhando para estas
previsões em termos abstratos
elas são na realidade bastante
extraordinárias
isso porque porque nestas eleições dos
três países há muitos partidos que vão a
votos nas últimas eleições do reino
unido concorreram mais de quatro anos
parte das listas dos estados unidos foi
um pouco menos 25 e queda de 30
mas mesmo assim reduzir o leque de
potenciais vencedores de 25 2 não é
fácil quanto mais de mais de 400
partidas e vistas como no reino unido
estatísticos é probabilidades
conseguiria citado no resultado das
eleições neste país escolhendo apenas
dois partidos em cada um saiu no país em
um grau de bambu e nada sociável
é mais fácil a citar quatro números e
uma estrela no euromilhões prolongado em
28 é mais fácil talvez não migrantes e
se alguém numa festa província
corretamente quatro números e uma
estrela do euromilhões
acho que queria estude muito
impressionados com o que está a
acontecer aqui que o vivente com sei
prever o que está por trás desta
realidade inesperada das missões do
vídeo aí que o governo está a fazer é
basicamente descrever os sistemas
partidários deste texto países
o que são sistemas praticidade sistemas
partidários são as interações entre as
partes
eu vou dar uma compressão que ajuda a
explicar o que são mais concretamente e
ajuda a explicar qual é a diferença de
sistemas partidários e partidos
políticos
então considero em um carro e um carro
tayo uma propriedade no central que é
capacidade de se mover autonomamente
certo em seu motor fase tua outra
propriedade do próprio nome auto 9
imagina e credos montam scavo pensar
pensa numa garagem
se isto foi o que eu tive que fazer para
preparar este interesse de contar editar
as rodas estão virados ao contrário pois
é que está amarelo e está não em breve à
aiea aceitam a pensar isso
então se por um lado temos todas as
peças do automóvel mas já não temos um
automóvel porque porque está a comemorar
a peça já não tem aquela propriedade
central de poder não ver autonomamente
[Música]
só temos um automóvel quando essas peças
estão em relação mas com as outras são
humilhadas do euro as outras quando
estão em interação umas com as outras e
portanto um automóvel é um sistema e as
peças são as partes que compõem a
sistema mas o sistema vai pra lá em das
partes tem algo a mais que as partes um
sistema partidário é com o nosso
automóvel é composto pelas interações
entre os vários partidos e os partidos
são as partes que compõem esse sistema
deste a sistema partidário que esteve
com o feminino e com as previsões de um
pai nos sistemas partidários a várias
interações
mas há uma que é central que é condição
pela liderança no governo
tipicamente esta condição providência do
governo estruturas há em torno de dois
partidos alguns casos entre os dois
blocos políticos
aquilo que o virem fins foi basicamente
descrever esta interação central nos
três países e ao fazer esta descrição
desta interação central que é quem
compete no governo eu consegui o
primeiro futuro porque estes sistemas
partidários do reino unido e estados
unidos
a albânia são sistemas partidários
construir lados institucionalizados nós
dizemos em ciência política e ao serem
construídos ao ser institucionalizados
só não estavas tornam os previsíveis e o
fato será imprevisíveis que torna estas
premonições do nosso vivente
estatisticamente estável em áreas mas
realmente triviais realmente algo que
qualquer pessoa que conheça a política
deste texto é isso que eu queria prevê
imagina em crise se encontram com este
incidente não agora mas há 20 anos atrás
será muito diferente das festas até da
queda do governo que não vá se nós
encontrarmos residente em 1997 teria que
o vidente seria capaz de fazer este tipo
de previsões para muitos mais países
conseguiria prover
quem vai ganhar e quem vai liderar o
governo depois das eleições seguintes
já em países como espanha itália irlanda
e grécia é a diferença entre muitos
outros e poderia fazer essas previsões
porque estes sistemas partidários é não
construir a eram previsíveis em 2017 e
sistemas para tirar já não são
previsíveis
agora é preciso ter sério saber quem vai
ganhar
não vou poder entrar na história todos
estes países mas sim em caso de
referência ilustres também os partidos
que as forças partidárias tenham
dominado a política francesa de 58 te
básicamente últimas eleições nem sequer
conseguiram chegar à segunda volta das
eleições há cinco anos atrás aqui o que
aconteceu agora é totalmente
inimaginável
honestamente nem o próprio emanuel na
com que eu queria conseguir aquilo que
aconteceu porque o que que o que sempre
questões é que está o implica que as
próximas eleições em países como espanha
e tal ea grécia frança sejam
imprevisíveis nós não sabemos o que vai
acontecer não sabemos quem vai ganhar
não sabemos quem vai governar e que tipo
de governo vai surgir depois tive que o
que tem consequências para explicar
porque quando falamos do crescia estamos
a falar essencialmente democracia
partidária
estamos a falar de democracia partidária
é porque
do processo democrático nós cidadãos
drogamos a em representantes eleitos é
capacidade de governar desprendendo que
as políticas públicas que esses
governantes não adotar refletem os
nossos interesses e preferências
só que esta ligação dos cidadãos aos
representantes não é feita diretamente
pelos partidos que o veículo é por isso
que existe a frase que certamente já
ouviram mais do que uma vez
cris que crescia não é possível em parte
quando olha para esta instância
neste contexto há duas visões da
república
uma é uma visão pessimista da visão
pessimista fazer a festa reunirá de
peixe copo e este copo está na ênfase
estava vazio porque com esta empresa
exibirá tamos a assistir ao surgimento
de novos partidos
muitos deus partidos populistas e
radicais
estamos a assistir a uma crescente
fragmentação eleitoral e fragmentação
partidária e essa instabilidade põe em
causa o próprio funcionamento da
democracia porque o sistema partidário é
crucial para o funcionamento da
democracia e em casos onde o sistema
partidário não é estável não está
institucionalizado o funcionamento da
democracia e afetado no limite é própria
sobrevivência da democracia
é posta em causa com um importante
estudo refere é difícil manter a
democracia de massas moderna
saem o sistema partidário
institucionalizada há uma visão
optimista e essa visão otimista
olha pro mesmo copo eles né não o copo
está na faixa que esta visão dijk e que
basicamente se é verdade que temos em
instruir agora é errado com os velhos
sistemas partilhar estão sob pressão
mesmo os sistemas partidários do reino
unido ao nerd estados unidos embora não
tenham começado com outros países mas a
verdade é que está aqui que estamos em
uma fase 13 selma faz um tipo de sistema
partidário institucionalizado para o
outro durante a transição
mas quando usava mas precisam voltar à
normalidade
qual destes cenários é que vai ocorrer
logo
eu não sou vidente eu não sei a resposta
agora não sei a resposta sai de quem
depende da resposta do futuro da
democracia nós olharmos para o que está
a acontecer a nível dos partidos e dos
sistemas partidários e pensar que é
causa é esse não partir de sistemas
partidários e que é social também tem
que ser é esse no sistema de partilha
os livros que não é isso não é apenas
isso é verdade que os sistemas
partidários e os partidos são muito
importante que saem partidos não há
democracia
contudo é importante lembrar que não é
só com
de que a democracia partidária é
importante mas a crise partidária não é
tolerável crescia e portanto é aquilo
que vai determinar o futuro da
democracia
diria que passa muito por esta esfera
extra partidária por aquilo que nós
fizemos não apenas dentro mas também
fora lembra aos que eu sistemas
partidários aos automóveis um automóvel
vai conduzir tendo em conta o contexto
onde está inserido
se eu colocar aqui um muro ou na
barreira
um carta é passar por aqui não vai ter
pensado álbum kreol seu crime e portanto
automóvel pode se mover mas pode se
mover dentro do seu contexto e os
sistemas partidários é a mesma coisa
podem participar
é muito importante também por onde não
tem tempo para orientar os sistemas
partidários para caminhos mais virtuosos
e ex índice futuro que foi a 80
como sabem neste filme o primeiro
original do mj o futuro
o o o herói umar vai entrar no carro do
seu amigo cientista
e vai para o pensava eu maio de 1985 em
1955 e o filme chama-se regresso ao
futuro porque depois tem conseguir
voltar 5585 tem conseguido cds ao futuro
estamos a contar isto porque a preparar
esta esta esta toque tripla primeira vez
o verdadeiro significado deste filme tem
que admitir que há dez anos quando vi
pela primeira vez que teve ali não é
esquisita essa bola mas agora parece que
seria verdadeira 00 cento e vestiu neste
filme o máquina que faz está em 1955 e
aquilo que eu faz em 1955 determina é
que vai ser o seu futuro não apenas o
véu individualmente marty mcfly o futuro
da sua família
o futuro da sua cidade em 85 total
dependendo daquilo com arte fizer em
1955 e da ump
o filme está a dizer é que na verdade
nós todos somos uma máquina pessoais
nós todos estamos é terminar o nosso
futuro não tivemos que entrar num carro
para voltar ao passado para fazer isso
mas de resto o processo é o mesmo que
estamos a definir o futuro
e tanto o desafio que se coloca é este é
pensarmos crédito crescia cremos e
participar ativamente para conseguir
essa democracia seja coisas pequenas
saem coisas grandes porque a pureza da
brinker e ciência
a beleza da democracia é seda o espaço
que permita a participação de todos
dentro dos partidos fora partir de
escala grande escala pequena mas todos
podemos participar porque cá escrevo
somos nós todos os dias
obrigado
[Aplausos]